always interesting seeing it through
another person's eyes
nice to see you here we brought the
soviet union
style into the american lives and so we
can check it out
and see how the girls dancing we have no
choice here
just grab the new car you're doing many
yeah many businesses
cost like 10 000 per month so what was
your biggest
shock babushka apartment where the baby
is old lady u.s citizens have to learn
from you what can you teach
careless never stress
good afternoon guys question for you
what comes to mind when i say
russian or ukrainian guy
most people actually don't know in the
west i'd say don't even
know ukraine is different than russia
but overall
it's usually the picture of the the
tough guy in the movies
you know the the bad guy the mafia guy
the vodka drinker
and i have a lot of affinity for that
part of the world i lived
there for four almost four years so
today
we have the great pleasure of meeting up
with the tally
and vitali is going to bring us into the
slavic world deep into the slavic world
here in miami beach there are a lot of
russians and ukrainians here
should be an adventure i know i know how
these people function
so i think it should be quite
interesting yeah let's do this
[Music]
here we are north side of miami beach we
have
matryoshka italian food
and vitale hello my friend
nice to see you thank you i have
recovered from corona so
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you had it
yeah how was it
um it's not the the best that i feel in
my life however
but it's not the worst okay man
thank you so much taking on the miami
fashion i didn't see those glasses in
keys yeah
this is the north side of miami greatest
area
and it is called the sunny isles beach
and this is the place where the most of
the
slavic or russian ukrainian people
concentrated
i would call it the mix it area because
we have a lot of people
from the former soviet union okay
so we have a tajikistan uzbekistan
armenia
so what what are we doing today so what
adventure are we gonna get into
uh we moved to miami like three and a
half years ago
yeah and so we opened our like an
exclusive
uh dance and fitness studio with an
outdoor area with the pole dancing and
everything so we can check it out
and see how the girls dancing and then
we can
can grab some food and i mean so you're
hitting the stereotype though vitaly now
you know ukrainian guy comes to america
starts pole dancing business
yeah okay that's your wife it's your
wife's
business
it looks like some good desserts here
[Music]
so this is this your go-to local eatery
yeah
for the one who missed the real
ukrainian
russian food you you know you can grab
everything you got it here huh
no i think it's a kind of uh american
style
coming into the russian ukrainian
businesses because you know this is the
this is the pretty american stuff to
make the rules and
put the fees and everything this was the
most
i mean surprising for me when we moved
here
yeah and i saw the rental agreement for
for the apartment like 27 pages or
something and then i had to
to get some documents some background
checks
and have all these fees you know and and
this is a pretty common stuff for the
for the
american people but it was really
surprising for me when you
when you moved to the states what three
years ago from ukraine from three and a
half
three and a half what was the first big
shock like been a culture shock for
like you were like wow i didn't expect
this or and i was surprised because i
thought the miami would be like the
dubai
was more of a party uh like more
more clean maybe or something like that
okay okay
we got uh we got an apartment on
hollywood beach
and we came at night yeah yeah so we
when we woke up i was shocked because i
i see um i i felt like i'm i'm in a real
village or something like this and i
because the
we started all this you know csi miami
yeah yeah this stuff
with the tallest buildings with
everything perfect
so i know and i asked my wife
all these buildings so
then we found out but yeah but now
they're here
right yeah yeah i mean this part of the
city is pretty nice
yeah when we were in the soviet union
with all these
restrictions and everything and then we
moved to miami
and looks like they are coming from you
from the soviet union uh you it's
because you guys you brought the
restrictions yeah
yeah yeah you flew them over we have
this expression in in ukrainian when you
when you know when
when you come from the area when the
rain raining now
so you can come you can say i i i
brought
the rain with me so the same we brought
the
soviet union style into the american
life
and meet my weird i wish i could say
thank you but it sounds terrible
yeah okay your friend yes he is my
friends maria
many people here in the sunny island
don't speak english at all so
i appreciate this opportunity you know
because i have an opportunity to speak
in english class yeah so you every every
day you guys are just working in russian
language
all the russian restaurants out there
when you get to the us
right yes the russia that the former
soviet countries it's like all you're
all brothers and sisters right when you
get here
all right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
because when you're in ukraine there's
some political stuff
right there's more tensions but here
because then it goes away right yeah
because for the most americans
here we all the russians so they people
we're
all russians how frustrating is that
when people say you say you're from
ukraine they're like oh you're from
russia
does it bother you i mean it's not not a
big deal no not a big deal
okay well when you live here you're just
yeah you're tired of
explaining every day just to explain to
those that don't know
the soviet union had 15 separate states
russia was the let's call it the
the nucleus yeah everything operated out
of moscow that was the big state yeah
yeah but there are 15 others ukraine
being one of them
ukraine the second populist the second
most popular city
so there's estonia lafayette lithuanian
crazy swath of geography and culture
all wrapped under one umbrella soviet
union 91 breaks up
ukraine goes its own way so now
sometimes depending where you're at in
the country
and who you're talking to they're like
we're very very pro-ukraine we want to
have nothing to do with russia
other people are like we want to have
something to do with russia it's very
complicated stuff i'm not even going to
try to explain here
but when you guys get here yeah it's
cool right yeah yeah yeah
everyone's one big family yeah yeah all
right
we have no choice here
we just give them to us what was your
biggest
shock let's say when you first moved to
united states when i come
here uh my biggest shock is
working on track you know work and why
working like movers
oh you worked as a mover yeah it's my
big shock it was a humbling experience
i live in drag 45 days you know you
lived in a truck 45 days
yeah bad for relationships huh are you
married
i but positive from this trip you know
i lose i think
23 kilograms
from 45 days like 50 pounds 50 pounds
yeah because
just grabbed the new car two days ago
for my wife
oh fantastic because she's pregnant now
oh congratulations she has thank you so
much and
she had the convertible two doors
and we decided it wouldn't be easy you
know to put the child
and open the top every time so we got
this
vitale where we going uh we are going to
check the
uh known uh
as a babushka apartment where the baby
is old lady yeah the old lady and what's
old lady
age was what do you what do you consider
babushka i think it depends on the
appearance
you know you can you can you can be
babushka in 40s
it's a fashion yeah it's a fashion it's
a kind of the way you think
the way you accept the life and
everything so i mean
it's like but check it out maybe you you
will see
okay you all know what it is
well i know i just i want to make sure
people watching know
i'm very familiar with the babushki
we call them the babushka mafiose
and it's a joke because in apartments in
ukraine at least the ones i lived in
there was always a collection of older
women at the bay at the ground level
letting you in
making sure no crooks got in
but more than that they really wanted to
know about your life
what your thoughts were who you're
dating uh
what your income is and this is because
they don't have um
they don't have an uh entertainment
in ukraine or in russia so the only way
to
to get entertainment yourself is to
to do some gossip something like that so
you
you can discuss with with your uh
babushka friends like
something about the neighbors
about the girls about the guys and
something like that babushka mafia so
they know more about your life than you
know about your life for example
you know is your relationship gonna last
is your kid gonna be successful or
a loser in life like yeah you know
are you are you sick or are you well
they'll even know if you're getting sick
before you do
they'll come in with borsch soup or
whatever so there's a very
as i'm joking here there's this very
human hospitable side
i enjoyed it sometimes it would get
annoying i gotta say when they'd always
be asking these questions
their algorithms better than facebook
yeah they know who's connected to whom
they know everything
everything in the system so what are you
doing for work here
vitale uh i do the life and business
coaching so i have
clients all around the world oh cool and
we opened the
dance and fitness studio here you and
your wife uh yeah
and we have some online shops for the
goods
my wife did their own design
um clothes so dancing
you're very entrepreneurial you're doing
many yeah
many businesses how is that been here is
the only way to
to live your best life in
in in miami because when when you got
hired
i mean when you just go to the
normal regular work you cannot afford a
good car
and something like that because the
wages right here they are lower
than in california for example or in new
york okay
so so i mean there are a lot of people
who
who who did their money i mean already
and then they moved to
they moved to florida so that's why we
here we have a lot of seniors
corona virus heaven here because
we have just some small restrictions
like you can
go inside a premises only with the mask
on
but i think that's it so you can
business is open
businesses open restaurants open clubs
even the clubs
and kara walk is everything is open
there are a lot of expensive apartments
here like a super expensive and super
luxurious and our friends live in this
apartment and
it cost like 10 000 per month so i mean
it's not
uh even it's not the cheapest
place to live in the united states so we
have a lot of
i mean this is the really fancy place
like you see there is the porsche
and luxury cars everywhere so i mean
this is the mix of people who
earned a lot of money and bring them
from ukraine or russia here with the
people who just moved
here and tried to survive and do some
business and something like that
we have a lot of politicians here also
who just
uh trying to hide here from the
ukrainian or
a russian government and sometimes when
you go to the beach you see somewhere
and i just remember this face i i
and then i remember okay this guy he's
he's stole like 10 million or something
from ukraine or from russia and now
he's they are searching for he
for this year but he's here just living
here
her his best life or something like that
so
many of russians they they start their
uh life in the united states from
uh doing business in russian or
ukrainian style
then they got got to the jail and then
they will
and then after that they start doing
business in american way
so you have to go to prison first yeah
to learn the rules
what about you do you want did you go to
prison no no i decided to go
you know to do in a different way so i
checked all this stuff i
i read everything i mean i got all the
permits and the lies and so now i'm
i'm happy that i can do this in a legal
and normal way
[Music]
how many years has she lived here
you speak english
21 years fantastic
little moscow russian from moscow from
london
she said there are a lot of famous and
uh like uh
superstars actors or
singers live here okay what is the best
thing about living in us what's the
worst thing about living in u.s
for me all albums for good i love
america
beautiful country from
uh she said there is now
in the united states it's the kind of um
you know the hard times with the
politics and everything
right but they are like an um senior
people
they're not trying not to be into it
so i mean maybe it's the best market the
best way is just
you know careless never stress it's
really weird times
in the us but you know what i see the tv
like everything looks like catastrophe
right looks like when you watch the tv
it all looks crazy
on the streets it's like especially
yeah normal it's completely it's it's
such a weird thing i have is
watching online and then i think
something's going to be terrible outside
and it feels
massive i live in california
dance but not here yeah you seen the
soviet world
you've seen this world what what do
americans
us citizens have to learn from you what
can you teach
patients to be patient
patient
thankful for all that you have and never
go to socialism
yeah that's true don't do that and you
see
peter this is this is i think this is
one of the point because they have lived
here
for 25 years of something
but they still you know feel the fear
i mean they are afraid of saying
true about the putin about the political
situation
in russia you think they're scared yeah
really
yeah or maybe this is the other trick i
will tell you right now
there may be a different trick because
when you move
you uh this is an ability of our brain
and of our memory you just remember the
good stuff
uh-huh and you after the years you just
forgot
everything bad happened that happens
right yeah
so when i was in ukraine living in there
at first i saw only the good like living
in a new country
in the beginning it's like a new
relationship absolutely and everything's
good and they can't do anything wrong
and then some reality starts to hit
starts to come through right
like and then and then if it's a good
relationship
yeah you stay with it yeah country is
like a routine
then the routine started yeah i don't
want to thrash on ukraine because i
i loved it i loved the culture a lot of
components of it i really love the
people i liked how authentic things were
but that's one part of the culture that
really sucks is that
horde take all and burn everything up
around you
yeah get the hell out yeah you know i
mean that exists everywhere but i think
there is
like one of the you know top places for
that sort of stuff
they say in russia like um there is the
expression like the
panti when it really matter for you
what the other people think about you
and you're trying you know
to to show to show you
not the life that you want to live but
the life the other want to see you live
like that i'm for example i'm a super
rich i'm a saver
uh i'm a super guy or something like
that so
that's that's the reason that
i can buy the super expensive car i mean
i cannot even sometimes
this is the part of the culture so
sometimes the people they just
cannot afford this type of car but
they they would better live in
some cheaper apartment
but they will definitely drive
some kind of porsche or even lamborghini
so my wife said because of soviet times
because people
didn't have anything absolutely it's
like it was suppressed so long
and now that it's allowed it's like to
the extreme the other way and this is a
good point you know this because i
remember when we moved
here and the first uh the first
couple days we just go to the shop to
the malls and
then buy everything that we see around
[Music]
it's like a country inside a country
florida
yeah yeah it feels like it it's all new
to me
so vitale being a an
immigrant mm-hmm how do you feel does is
it an easy adjustment are people cool do
you feel like uh the culture's open to
it or what are your thoughts on that
i think they're pretty cool when they're
open and i think that
the one of the pros for me
of the florida is that they're almost
the 70 percent of the people who
live in florida they was born were born
not
in florida okay they're all immigrants
so i mean i
i feel this i i have never seen any
you know any um racism or something like
that here
so the people mostly friendly
they have their own cultures and they uh
they're open to accept the culture
from others that's the main the main
point for me
because they are not you know closed
maybe it's because
here's like here we have like a 70
percent people here
they are latin americans or from
or cubans right so they speak mostly
spanish and we have like a ten percent
of the population it's
russian speaking okay ten percent yeah
something like that wow so it's pretty
much
and the everyone there's no problems
between the two
groups no no no you don't feel it i mean
the only problem
but it's everywhere is when the if the
person
is the but that person it doesn't matter
the race or
right right skin colors or something
like that so
it's just about the person so
do you wish you learned spanish before
coming here i wish i could speak spanish
yeah
that's true because sometimes they even
drop the you know the phone when when
they call you
and try to to talk with you in spanish
and then you say oh guys stop i
i i don't speak spanish at all and they
ah didn't just
hang up the phone so never mind
russian kindergarten here so this is a
whole nother russian zone
[Music]
all right
not a fancy one okay
natalie's quite a character this is fun
interesting always interesting seeing it
through another person's eyes
how did that go from being a doctor and
being well
known to being an uber driver it's
called the ball fitness
and the postport is the different stuff
if you want to grow
in the new country when you move you
have to be prepared to
what would they think of in ukraine if
they heard all this you guys have your
own
own universe here really absolutely they
are trying to
make people more dependent happy wife
happy life what can i say
more it's hard because i'm 50. and this
is the one of the
pros of the united states they call it
hachi puri
in ukraine no one can even think this
way
russian food in a romanian restaurant
with the jews
owner i mean the bazaar you know
is it good